pour Cathy Bourgoin l'émotion est trop
forte je pleure de joie de soulagement
pour mon gamin et puis pour tous nos
enfants un sentiment de victoire pour
Cathy dont le fils est mort sur la route
percuté par un chauffard désormais lors
d'un accident mortel le terme employé
sera homicide routier et non plus
homicide involontaire difficilement
supportable par les familles des
victimes ce nouveau délit s'appliquera
en cas de feu rouge grillés ou d'excès
de vitesse et lorsque le conducteur aura
consommé de l'alcool et ou des
stupéfiants c'est un symbole important
parce que pour les victimes et les
familles de victimes il est intolérable
il est inacceptable d'entendre parler
d'homicides involontaire la création de
cette nouvelle qualification et le
combat d'une décennie pour Cathy ces
remèdes de l'humain dans la justice
croyez-moi ces symbolique elle compte
énormément pour nous mais les
associations restent déçues elles
aimeraient que le l'habitude de victimes
soit mieux reconnue avec une prise en
charge plus rapide de la justice dans
les cas d'homicides certains auraient
aussi voulu un alourdissement des
sanctions aujourd'hui 10 ans de prison
et 150000 euros d'amende leur domicile
sous l'emprise de l'alcool ou de
stupéfiant difficile de tous les
connaître heureusement on s'accorde sur
l'essentiel le cœur rouge l'amour à la
place d'écrire je t'aime j'envoie juste
un cœur rouge la différence avec le cœur
noir
attention moins fort que le rouge je le
connaissais pas mais du coup la haine
Paris rencontrer sur un terrain de
pétanque ah vous avez rencontré votre
premier mari sur un terrain de pétanque
oui c'est rare ça sur un terrain de
pétanque je jouais à la pétanque oui
d'accord d'accord très bien donc ça
c'est fait ok du coup je me suis dit
changement de boule lyonnaise
c'est une bonne réponse bonne réponse
j'aime
ce sont la pandémie et le télétravail
qui ont révélé des failles chez certains
des Partena et ira donc le laisser aller
ou encore la prise de conscience de la
négligence de son partenaire changement
de Gaulle oui oui lyonnaise alors
numéro 2 compagnon numéro 2 d'autres
boules donc oui
lyonnaise lyonnaise ok terrain plus long
dans les Schtroumpfs il y a pas une
fille
comment elle s'appelle la seule fille
des Schtroumpfs je sais pas moi mais non
je sais pas
les deux copines n'ont pas réussi à
trouver la réponse à temps et son
sanctionner d'une minute supplémentaire
la solution à cette énigme était la
Schtroumpfette et le bleu il a une
longue histoire après au Moyen-Âge
notamment en Europe figurez-vous que
c'était pas la couleur du tout des
hommes mais la couleur des femmes parce
que la Vierge était établie en bleu
tandis que les hommes portaient du rose
puis ça a changé après il y a eu des
clichés tout ça et maintenant on fait ce
qu'on veut avec les couleurs n'est-ce
pas est-ce qu'on voit là c'est 2013
figurez-vous que les Bretons ont décidé
de faire le plus grand smiley humain
jamais organisé
quand même à se réunir avec des ponchos
noir et jaune c'est assez exceptionnel
c'est logique qui sourient j'avoue que
j'aurais peut-être un petit peu de mal à
m'en passer maintenant sinon ça fait
genre ok en ce moment vu que je suis
célibataire je parle qu'à mes potes donc
ça va être plus du tu sais le smiley
avec les larmes ce qui rigole
on m'envoie des abonnés
je commence à me faire vieux je crois le
clin d'oeil voilà et j'ai tendance aussi
à le faire quand je l'écris ou je le
tape voilà le clin d'oeil et le sourire
alors tout vient en fait des calculs des
experts de l'Institut économique
molinariques qui comme chaque année
établit un classement des pays d'Europe
les plus taxés l'an dernier la France
avait été dépassée par l'Autriche mais
cette année c'est à nouveau notre pays
qui se place en tête des pays européens
les plus taxés
l'intermitami où il a signé
officiellement présenté hier sa nouvelle
recrue c'est sous la pluie mais dans
l'euphorie que 20 000 femmes ont assisté
à cette intronisation du septup le
Ballon d'Or Lionel Messi qui s'est
engagé jusqu'en 2025 dans le club de
Miami avec un salaire estimé entre 45 et
55 millions d'euros par saison contre 30
quand il était au PSG la conséquence
c'est qu'en combinant tous les
prélèvements obligatoires c'est à dire
les impôts comme l'impôt sur le revenu
les cotisations sociales comme la CSG
les cotisations chômage et puis la TVA
avec ses multiples taux et bien les
Français travail entièrement pour l'État
et uniquement pour l'État jusqu'au 16
juillet et évidemment il travaille aussi
pour financer les dépenses publiques et
notre modèle social pas l'oublier c'est
donc seulement à partir de ce lundi ce
lundi 17 juillet que les Français
commencent à travailler pour eux-mêmes
c'était le 9 août l'an dernier et donc
17 juillet cette année
bizutage en chanson pour le nouvel
entraîneur adjoint du Racing Club de
Strasbourg et non il ne s'agit pas du
comédien Eric Judor beaucoup
d'internautes ont été frappés par la
ressemblance entre Paul neuvin et
l'humoriste sur les réseaux sociaux les
gifs et les superlatifs se multiplient
certains n'en reviennent toujours pas
devant ce sosie ultime
c'est un bus qui a très longtemps foutu
la trouille au superstitieux je vais
vous le montrer vous avez tout de suite
comprendre pourquoi bienvenue à bord de
cette ligne
666 en direction de Hal qui veut dire en
anglais l'enfer en polonais c'est juste
le nom d'une presqu'île paradisiaque ou
des milliers de touristes à plus chaque
été pour les tremper les pieds dans la
mer Baltique
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça faisait 17 ans que absolument rien de
s'était passé à bord de la ligne 666 ni
accident niagression ni sorcellerie à
répéter le responsable des transports de
cette presqu'île oui mais voilà sous la
pression de groupe chrétiens crois
savoir les médias locaux après un
article indigné sur un site d'extrême
droite polonais ce bus vient d'être
rebaptisé sa date de cet été ligne 669
un chiffre moins controversé et en même
temps il y a des détails qui nous
rébusent mais qui nous réduitent parce
que nous ne sont plus habitués à voir le
son la saleté quand on regarde le regard
de cet enfant on se dit mon dieu mais
que des forts pour naître voilà c'est là
où il y a le courage de renouerg de ne
pas sublimer et de ne pas faire de ce
moment un moment magique et idéalisé
la canette tu vois des canettes de quoi
les canettes de la femelle du canard
et là Laura elle a compris canette
[Musique]
donc on a 42 ans
moi j'étais très déçu parce que quand
cette chanson est sortie j'étais dans 71
donc ça me faisait 30 ans lors du ménage
et mince c'est par accord vous faites
pas oui c'est gentil merci et ça fera
pas marquer un point quoi qu'il arrive
vous faites plus alors
à part ça donnez-lui quelque chose de
rond à faire rentrer dans un trou dans
un panier dans une poubelle ou même dans
une tasse
et Stephen Curry serait bien capable de
le faire
[Applaudissements]
138 m en un seul coup ça vaut bien un
petit footing